we're back to do three more episodes and
then they go on their hiatus ah I guess
we'll just start off by saying um after
this we will do an overview log series
we're kind of split over which one we
should do next either one that we've I
wanted to do the 80s classic Rainbow
Brite and was voted down well after they
would you eat your salons and it would
fall Oh colorful than this show if it
was the it's the only joke that got like
you know the most response is our family
opera review everybody was just like I
remember that no most no were like for
those two like you don't know the
classics oh that was one of the girls
shows that watch allows a low-key out
see I just said like I like the bad guy
you're funny you just wanted a world
without color
I want to be dark and gray like murky
and Lurky I'll bring it really sight
back so we don't know what we're gonna
do yet you don't need to write a million
do this do that we got like maybe three
or four that it's like okay it's one of
these we just don't know which why it's
gotta be yet but yeah we're gonna go
through these three and this one is uh
kind of a great little contender yes ah
and this uh little bit of a slow start
not gonna lie you know yeah the song and
everything but you wanna know what my
might absolute favorite part of this is
the very very beginning and the very
very ending I love that quiet when
they're just sitting there looking out
at the sunset but it's also like
foreboding somehow like you know yeah
it's the calm before the storm kind of
it's like that scene them Alaska bus
with the giraffes crying you're crying
um and then I like the bit at the end
where she has the diamond and and you
don't know why you don't know what
that's gonna do
ah you don't know that's a good thing or
a bad thing uh so both of it I think I
like both the feeling of I don't know
how to accept this scene I really like
seeds that can do that where it's just
it's this extreme good feeling that's
extreme it was fine I was just happy the
whole episode wasn't it cuz it got
intense at the end of them look good
like as I was rid of like it's gonna be
an all song episode what
berated Oh like yeah look at the office
I saw sound of music like everyone else
why is it and we saw the one where it's
like she's being introduced to the world
and stuff but what I do like is that it
you know I think with anyone you're not
gonna win somebody over in just a half
hour segment or an hour's I mean it's
like even if you think you have a one
over I mean it's like you're never fully
gonna have them it's like the what's
that line it's like whatever religion
you're raised on that's always gonna be
a part of you even if you become 80s or
boots or whatever like a bad penny
like if you were raised I've kept I'd
kill to the day I die I don't care if
I'm Buddhist pagan or Jedi I like if
you're you know raised Jewish but then
become Buddhist or something like that
like that Jew it you're in juvie never
boy yes ooh maybe that was like The Da
Vinci Code three um but um yeah so where
are you going with this ah I was pretty
much saying that because you know it's
one of those things where a character
shouldn't just immediately flip around I
think although we see it a lot and we
usually accept it but I kind of like you
see constantly through this not just hey
I'm evil at the very end where that even
wants to be evil you see it's hard to
letting this stuff go cuz she's just
been paradigm talking about has been
raised on this stuff just all her life
and has had this great admiration for it
and then just suddenly in a few weeks
she's supposed to be something else I
love that scene to where she's just like
check out what they were gonna do this
would have been awesome and I'm like
sitting there like oh it didn't mean the
extinction of my species I'm like yeah I
mean it looks I love I'm like a sign of
that earth after everything's down oh I
want to see what they like by the way
the fuck hip in the Russia yeah this
area's just got this giant like my Bay
or lake or ocean like in the middle of
Siberia you know I don't know um you
know um geography and stuff very well
but I saw who I saw that I have for a
second I was just like was there a hole
there like was there's something just oh
no that made me laugh because you were
literally the world's worst person at
geography like you've got no I toasted
before
you noticed yeah and you did and I'm
like wait what are you talking about
like well I wasn't looking at Russia I
was looking at weird a little dot well I
just notice I'm so used to seeing this
map of the world and there's just a big
hole time like oh so that's also very
foreboding um and uh yeah name a few
countries at border Russia let's just um
I'm just gonna sing the Animaniacs Yakko
song United States Canada Mexico Panama
82 make up a room none of which I
motivation um sure I can see Russia from
my house uh but yeah this is this is an
episode that I think starts off slow but
then gets like really good
yeah it's again it's peridot I fucking
love a pair about uh you know she's like
sort of becoming my new favorite
character itchy it's like a time now
between me and between her and garlic
and just to think a day ago she wanted
to kill us well technically it was a few
weeks ago um and I just you get it you
get why she's like this and why she
can't just flip around and suddenly
she's let go she's like very mature for
a brown Church she's just she's been
indoctrinated and she drank the kool-aid
and now she's having to it's almost like
deprogramming her it's like oh it's not
just all the kool-aid I've drank it like
there's another reality here and I think
it's hard for her to accept it well I
think because she was so excited to see
all that stuff and see the destruction
of her and start going off on how they
actually made things worse when she has
that diamond at the end you legitimately
don't know it's this a good thing or a
bad thing you know is she looking to
make things better is she like you know
a free and show you um so I really like
that I like not really knowing what
she's up to
um and I'm wondering what that other
room is forward to they go by and say
what what's this room it's not important
that they keep walking it's like um it's
why I was like come on Charlie let's
take a sip really welcome honest I
thought he was gonna stay behind and do
something there but merrily not well and
what I like to see is you know with uh
with peridot like going in it's like you
can't sit there only the highest elders
sit there it's like but they're not here
anymore and she said that great ha ha
laughs that she has throughout the whole
thing I was just thinking like think
she's got a little bit of a power trip
cuz these are heroes and she's like I'm
sitting in the chair again I'm trying to
look at like the other way around like
let's say it was like you know I don't
know like the the White House or
something and there's like the
president's chair or something like that
say it it'd be weird cuz it's like the
president's chair it's like but if
whatever the all humanity was gone or
something it just healing still see my
gonna get whiskey steak um a little bit
of cigar a shot but yeah it's one of
those things where it's like when you
when you're in that situation it I can
identify with her even though she wants
to do something you know or is having a
hard time getting away from that life of
doing really really bad things so well
it's the closest she's ever gonna be to
a position of power I think is the irony
of it yeah sitting in that chair so um
yeah I like I liked uh garnets know Oh
life is precious
now let me demonstrate with my fist
anytime they have a reflection hold it
guys dim occasion
hello whatever they do like a reflection
or goggles I always think it's like I'm
always waiting for that kind of shot or
when they get it so close like you can't
see at the outline of the black hair so
it's just like black and then her
goggles in her mouth and that's it I
always think I'm so cool um but uh yeah
try to think of a much else here um yeah
I think it's one of those things where
it is good to know that like you know as
you said deprogramming doesn't work
quickly and even when you think it's
worth day you know there's always gonna
be it's in there that's because in her
case they're not actively trying to D
it's not like they strapped her down to
a chair and are like putting on some
sort of routine it's more like she's
just a climatic to her new environment
so when she doesn't want to be a part of
that environment either but she's just
kind of chosen to cuz it's her best
option and then they did a few nice
things okay I guess I could do a few
night thing but it's she very
begrudgingly does all this so it kind of
makes sense that she would be like that
so yeah I like it
i like i said i think the pair dad
episodes are just the coolest episodes
to me that they're they're funny and
they're interesting and
it's just a really great character so I
concur in do you concur I concur
we concur will reference other movies
probably 10 years old and the next
people catch me if you can I concur
instead of